j'aurais pu ne pas la ramasser comme
tout le monde au calme après tout c'est
pas moi que j'étais il ya un monde qui
payez pour amasser ça
six appels à vis de la canette
d'où ils sont comment elle est recyclé
qu'est ce qu'elle rapporte comment jean
tout ça
peut-être que c'est le cas lors une
valeur pour moi
aujourd'hui la canette à la réunion lé
pas recyclés à l'étrier
l explosion nazis la balle est refondu
elle reprend
qui un jour peut être reviendront la
réunion
ça paraît comme une coupe
care for sip une canette ça ça coûte
combien ça nous rapporte combien
finalement quelle est la valeur de cette
canette
le coude le cours d'hier achats des
canettes aluminium
aujourd'hui c'est 900 euros la tonne
ça fait combien de cannes est hyper fun
il en faut 72000
ça nous fait un bien qu'ils 25 centimes
d'euro la can est aujourd'hui la
consigne sur les chopines de bière ces
quatre centimes d'euro
donc en gros il faudrait soixante dix
mille canettes pour ce faire 900 euros
un peu compliqué quand on a un exemple
simple soit si vous avez déjà vu des
cendriers fabriqué en canette
ça prend ça
avec un ciseau
comprendre ça un euro
donc déjà y'a pas tout l'idée deux dents
voyez là-bas en asie de faire fondre et
c est là on a déjà si on en vend 72000
72 mille euros
moins de travail maintenant après un
cendrier c'est pas pas forcément message
positif donc peut-être quelque chose de
plus utile donc pour que ce soit et il
faut qu'on regarde autour de nous quelle
est la forme de la canette
qu'est ce que cette can est à quoi elle
ressemble
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait en faire
regarde autour de nous il ya des c'est
pas ma dvr des vases des poutres
filloux
c'est pas si vous êtes déjà brûlé au
robinet quand les tuyaux et dehors en
plein soleil
en fait si le fait que le tuyau est
sombre qu'il est noir c'est que ça brûle
comme ça du coup un chauffe eau solaire
basiquement
c'est un tuyau peint en noir
il ya les panneaux photovoltaïques ça se
chauffe à l'électricité via les panneaux
solaires donc là c'est le noir qui vient
chauffer le tuyau
la appartement canettes comment je peux
faire un tuyau un chauffe eau solaire va
falloir faire commencer par ouvrir ses
canettes dans les deux sens du terme
dans son script steam ou faisaient de
canettes ou vieux ouvre les yeux
regarder partout et à les bains dans la
ravine à l'arrêt de bus autre case même
un parking partout il ya deux canettes
récupérer vos canettes
cette fois-ci vous les ouvrez pour de
vrai
haut en bas avec un ouvre-boîte un
ciseau un cutter et là vous les
assemblées sous forme de tuyaux baigner
en noir fait en sorte que ça fuit pas
vous avez déjà un chauffe eau solaire
pour pousser un peu plus l'idée pouvait
faire un
une boîte
bois de palettes
tellement de récupérer du polystyrène
pour isoler le tout et prendre des verts
déçu de vr dans les miroirs tri pour
avoir un produit 100% local donc là on a
une base technologie qui répond
basiquement au besoin on à la haye
technologie et la halle aux technologies
et moi d'autres ça j'ai pas inventé
l'eau chaude
vous devrez vous devez moi j'ai juste
fait qu'adapter ce que j'ai vu sur
internet en un canadien fait ça depuis
plus de vingt ans il a fait un tutoriel
pour partager l'idée unis le fait avec
de l'air impôts chauffer sa maison
je sais dit bah oui mais dans l'est au
maïdo plein des caves peut-être mais
est-ce qu'on aurait besoin c'est un
produit moins cher et locales
donc comment faire de manière artisanale
un produit utile avec ça
et pas si compliqué
c'est une nourriture saine c'est tout ce
qu'on voit
terre-net fait le par vous même des
tutoriels qui facilite la transmission
de connaissances et le triture self
c'est la clé j'irai même c'est le mot
clé par exemple vous les cherchez une
solution pour le recyclage tapé do it
yourself kahn est elle tombée sur par
exemple une machine dépendent de pop
corn fait avec deux canettes pas non
pour les bouteilles plastiques tapé do
it yourself août et plastiques faut
tomber sur les littoraux flight
light sondés
de gains aux philippines
et des ampoules des puits de lumière
avec des bouteilles plastiques et
remplissent d'eau avec un petit peu de
javel
il permet d'avoir deux
meyer dans les bidonvilles aux
philippines ils sont même allés jusqu'à
inventer un petit
anoh photovoltaïque avec une lettre pour
moins d'un dollar pour un bel éclairage
sur les joues
je veux donner un deuxième exemple avec
les bouteilles plastiques cette fois-ci
faut casser un peu le le côté faille
qualité mauvaise qualité quality bon
marché et coûte cher mais en vrai on
peut utiliser les défauts de nos déchets
en tant que valeur par exemple les
bouteilles plastiques dans la nature
c'est 100 à 1000 ans à se dégrader
donc quand on utilise des voûtes et
plastique pour fabriquer un mur on prend
les bouteilles plastiques on les remplit
dans le peuple
un anneau bri ça nous permet d'avoir un
mur plus épais plus solide plus isolants
et moins chers qui utilisent moins de
béton et en plus on peut rendre sa jolie
avec un an j ça a été fait à madagascar
à tamatave et un peu partout dans le
monde grâce aux vidéos et aux tutoriels
il ya la possibilité
répandre ces idées là
et communautés autour de tout ça partout
dans le monde les gens cherchent des
solutions et avec internet on peut y
avoir accès de n'importe où
savait que la 4g le réseau cattier ses
dépens
rapidement que les réseaux électriques
dans les pays émergents qu'on est
capable d'avoir le même accès à la
connaissance au milieu de la brousse
comme dans un bureau de coordination
talent
c'est là en fait l'espoir c'est que des
solutions il y en a des milliers
adapté finalement allé celle de nos
territoires
quand on regarde la réunion 7 ce caillou
c'est un million d'habitants environ on
a la possibilité d'influencé et de
tester des choses en commun
avec nos îles voisines on a cinq îles
francophones qui ont
peyrens économique mais qui ont un trait
d'union ce trait d'union il est mondial
c'est les déchets cette can est scellé
la retrouver à la réunion comme partout
dans le monde allez standardisés
cette solution sera répliquée par tout
en cherchant des solutions communes à
nos problèmes communs
on peut trouver un modèle de société
durable commun et ramener un peu de
positif dans tout ça
on entend souvent
et les rapports
miss on
le monde va mal et de toute façon c'est
foutu que on fonce droit dans le mur
qu'on pourra pas sauver le monde
on entend souvent c'est non en
répétition
il nous appartient d'essayer de faire
différemment
qaïsi pas capable heymans ont essayé je
vais passer mes
aux devises l'euro
ramener un peu de positif et désire aux
jeunes réunionnais et à tout
entrepreneur d'essayer des solutions
essayer d alternative parce qu'on est
bien là ici pocket chose c'est pour
partager des idées
une fois je
amiens - tu me demander comment je
faisais pour pour rester optimistes
malgré tout ce qui se passe
j'ai répondu que si on regarde pas
nous-mêmes l'espoir on ne peut pas le
partager merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]